When we want to categorize living organisms
in a complicated way,
we can divide them into
eukaryotes or eukaryotes
or prokaryotes.
Prokaryotes ...
The biggest difference
between prokaryotes and eukaryotes are membrane-restricted structures,
which the eukaryotes have, and the prokaryotes - not.
The most obvious difference is the presence of a membrane-bound core.
In a eukaryotic cell, genetic information is found
inside the core, which is bounded by a membrane.
Here it is - this is the core.
Your genetic information is in it,
this is your DNA.
In the prokaryotic cell, your DNA would look like this.
It may be at one end of the crew
We call this nucleotide, but it is not limited to a membrane like the nucleus.
Time to write it ...
No membrane ...
There is no core membrane bound.
There is no core bounded by a membrane.
This is not the only difference between
prokaryotes and eukaryotes.
This is just the most noticeable difference.
In fact, in the word "eukaryotes" the "carriot"
comes from the Greek word for "stone" or "kernel".
Let me write it ...
This means "stone"
or "nut".
"Prokariot" means "before the kernel or the stone".
We can look like nuts or stones
these membrane-bound structures,
especially the kernel you see here.
But that's not all.
The eukaryotes also have other membrane-bound structures,
which prokaryotes do not have.
You can see mitochondria,
my-it-chores
in a eukaryotic cell, plant or animal,
but you will not find them in a prokaryotic cell.
And there are other types of structures. membrane bounded
You will see things like Goldie's apparatus.
This is a microscope picture of a eukaryotic cell.
And here's the Goldie apparatus,
which helps in the synthesis of proteins.
This is a microscopic picture of mitochondria,
and that of the core.
This is the nuclear membrane.
And this is the genetic information,
all this here.
It is in the form of chromatin (uncompressed chromosomes).
Here is quite crowded,
as we have shown it on the diagram.
So it's DNA in the form of a chromatin,
but in the part that looks even thicker and darker,
the microscope picture below
we see the kneeling.
her-wife
This is the place,
where ribosomal RNA is produced.
Ribosomal RNA, which is part of the ribosomes,
who play an important role in the process of translation or
in simple words - the synthesis of proteins,
based on the information in the RNA.
We will discuss this in detail in other videos.
These ribosomes here
are constructed from ribosomal RNA
and proteins.
Here's where they're building - in the kneeling,
the dense part of the core.
The major difference between prokaryotic and eukaryotic cells is,
that the eukaryotes have a core limited by a membrane
other membrane-bound structures such as mitochondria.
There are theories that
mitochondria have first developed into prokaryotic organisms,
who lived in symbiosis
inside a larger eukaryotic cell.
And the other difference is,
that in eukaryotes, DNA is in multiple chains.
So if you decide to straighten the DNA molecule,
you will get multiple chains.
In the prokaryotic cell, the DNA is ring-shaped.
It can fold in different directions,
but generally ring-shaped.
These are the three main differences:
nuclear membrane, other membrane-bound organelles
such as the mitochondria or the apparatus of Goldie and
also the multicellular DNA in the eukaryotes
or annular DNA in the prokaryotes.
In addition, eukaryotic cells are usually larger,
unlike prokaryotes that are smaller and simpler.
Once we know the main differences,
to give examples of eukaryotes?
Most organisms are eukaryotic,
with which we have access every day
or we think we have a touch every day.
Including all multicellular organisms ...
very much
I mean animals, plants and mushrooms.
Here are the unicellular ones.
This is a slipper here.
It is a eukaryote.
There is a core surrounded by a membrane
and other organelles.
Here are cells from the top of the onion root,
they are plant cells
You can see it because it is colored,
these are the nuclei of the cells.
This is a nice picture because you can see
cells at various stages of mitosis,
which is very interesting.
Animal cells and your own cells
are also eukaryotic.
Then what are the prokaryotic cells?
Well, the simplest example is bacteria.
These are bacteria
and are prokaryotic organisms.
And the smaller things,
or those that are rarely spoken by the archaeans.
First, people thought arches were bacteria,
who just live in
extreme conditions.
But now it is known that they are a different kingdom -
kingdom archaeus.
When we talk about overpopulations or empires,
it is often thought that bacteria are one branch,
and the arches - another.
Archaeas are here ...
And eukaryotes are also a separate branch,
I will paint them here.
And with eukaryotes there are all things,
for which we have already spoken
here are plants and animals,
mushrooms and unicellular,
and similar.
So, on a higher level of understanding
we can consider archaea and bacteria as prokaryotes,
and these, of course, are eukaryotes.
I hope this explains things well.